never been an Israel hater. Obviously,
I'm not an anti-semite. I just don't
want more wars and I don't want a
foreign country humiliating my country
and telling us what our laws have to be.
I mean, this seems like pretty basic
America first stuff. And he would say,
"I totally agree with you, but they want
you off the stage." And I would always
say, "No problem." And he would say,
"No, it's important, but I think it's
important to say that out loud because
it's a fact." And there are many liars
out there trying BB Netanyahu number one
among them shamefully
who are trying to distort the truth.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Alhamdulillah. The
whole world is waking up to these scum
bastards. That's what they are.
Guys, before the video starts, brothers
and sisters, one Umar is working in
Pakistan with the flood that's hit the
country. 1,700 people have lost their
life. Millions of people have lost their
homes and been displayed. So the videos
that you can see here, the pictures that
you can see guys is demonstrating what
onem is doing on the ground. We know
Gaza is important and we know what's
going on there. But brothers and
sisters, we cannot enable and turn a
blind eye to the suffering of Muslims in
different countries. Be it Pakistan, be
it Turkey, the earthquakes, wherever it
may, be Afghanistan, so many other
places need our help. And I know all of
us have given as much as we can to Gaza.
But brothers and sisters, wahi, just
imagine your home wrecked. Thousands of
people have died. Your family members
have passed away. You have nowhere to
live. Brothers and sisters, they need
our help as much as Gaza does. So I urge
you guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. Donate whatever amount, even if
it's£1. The prophet peace be upon him
said the best form of sodak is to give
water. Brothers and sisters, let's give
them food and shelter and water to drink
so they can overcome this tragedy.
Inshallah, I urge you guys to go to the
link and donate now. Enjoy the video.
Brothers and sisters, dear friends, many
people are now coming out with text
messages proving further how Charlie
Kirk was changing his mind. Now we've
got Dave Smith, the comedian that you
know, who's a Jewish person himself is
exposing Israel. Not only that, Tucker
Carlson came out as well to demonstrate
this. Now, watch this for yourself,
guys, cuz this is mind-blowing. They are
reading text messages and showing where
Charlie Kirk was heading and who
benefits. They say if you want to find
the culprit of who may have killed
somebody else, ask a simple question.
Who benefits from his death? Who? Who?
The Palestinians. Huh? Does the
Palestinians? No. The Palestinians were
being massacred. They don't want another
one person massacred. Even though they
disagree with him, they don't. And not
only that, they was he was solely
towards the end. Let's judge him by
towards the end. Who benefited from it?
No one but Israel. Nobody but Israel and
Trump because he was talking about the
Epstein vials. So, brothers and sisters,
here is a video of um Dave Smith reading
text messages and exposing the liar
Satan Yahoo. Let's watch for ourselves.
From Sunday, April 13th at 8:01 p.m. Uh
he texts me, "Listen to you on Rogan."
This is like a day or two after the
Douglas Murray debate. Uh so, I debated
Douglas Murray on the Joe Rogan uh
experience. Um and it was a big show. At
the time, it was a big show. I guess
Owens changed the definition of big show
at this point. In hindsight, a teeny
little show. Um but uh so this is this
was Charlie Kirk unprompted texted me
about the Douglas Murray debate. Now,
just like kind of keeping in mind and I
won't fully disclaim here. Charlie Kirk
is a really nice guy. You could chalk a
lot of this up to him being nice, but
the Douglas Murray debate with me, you
know, like I'm not overstating this was
like a big this may have been the
biggest high-profile debate on Israel.
And this this is what Charlie Kirk wrote
to me Sunday, April 13th.
>> Okay, listen now. So, this is the debate
that he had and you know, he was
ruthless. You know, Dave Smith was
ruthless and he exposed Douglas Murray,
the gutless Murray, the coward that he
is. Look at the message now. Let's see.
Was he against it? Did he say Dave
Smith, you know, I totally disagree with
what you're saying. Let's see how much
he loved Israel. Mr. Setanyahu, you
liar.
>> 1 p.m. listening to you on Rogan. You
did well despite me being more on the
pro-Israel side. Very little I disagree
with what you said. One point when
Douglas was going on about you using
arguments from authority. It's
ridiculous claim. You were using
original source quotes to prove their
motives. All capital motives, not their
analysis of geopolitics, etc. Two
totally different things. You were right
on that point 100%. Keep up the good
work. Hope to cross paths.
>> Okay, good. Does that sound Does that
sound like something Israel will be
happy with that that message there? Does
that sound This is in private by the way
in confidentiality. He's speaking to
her. Does that sound like something
Israel will be happy with? Does that
sound like BB Nate this scumbag dirt
about Setanyahu saying that he loved
Israel, etc.? Nope.
>> Some point soon. I'm sorry. Hope to
cross paths at some point. And I wrote
back, "Thanks, Charlie. I really
appreciate that." Now, again, I'm not
saying anyone should make any more of
this than there is there, but like this
is Charlie Kirk. He told me privately
that there was very little that he
disagreed with.
>> Very little he disagreed with. And you
know that they probably call him hate,
self-hating Jew. Yes. Dave Smith. And if
you go listen to what I said on that
show, I was going pretty hard. And so I
will say like, you know, Candace is
calling on me to like release what I
know. That is one. And I think that's
not completely ins. And I salute Candice
for that. Release those messages.
Everybody release the messages to show
the reality of the world. Everyone
knows. The second time to come out and
say no, we didn't kill him. Why are you
so we didn't kill him. We didn't kill
him. It's like reminds me of the Quran
where Allah tells us that the hypocrites
will come and say, "Oh, we know you're
the messenger of Allah. Oh, we know
you're the Allah." But why you keep
repeating him, bro? Why why if you know
I'm the messenger of Allah, why why you
keep repeating it? Cuz you know you
don't believe it.
>> Yeah. Like I think that does at least
demonstrate that this wasn't Ben
Shapiro. Ben Shapiro was not sending me
this text message. Let's just say that,
you know? I mean, I don't want anyone to
make too much of this. I'm just kind of
putting the information out there. I
guess we've already established you're
going to make it what you will. Um and
then he said, "We should do a podcast in
person and have a fun, light-hearted,
contrasting conversation on Israel. I
bet we actually agree on most of it.
Truly, I will." And then he said, "I
will not scold you for not being." So he
made a neverbe joke and said, "I'm going
to need that in writing." And then he
said, "Screenshot it." And um okay, I
didn't actually plan on screenshotting
that or reading that aloud ever at any
point. So look, there you go. So you can
see clearly he went into a podcast and
you can see he was changing his mind on
Israel. Here is a video from Candace
Owen telling us what Tucker Carlson had
to say. Watch this guys because this is
very important for you guys to follow
this up guys. This is showing the
reality of these evil dirt bags. Yes.
And this is so fundamental for you to be
clued up and know and follow Candace
Owens's lives which I am closely
following because she is exposing this
whole thing.
>> BB Net and Yahoo trying to spin this
into he's my good friend. I just invited
him. Well, Tucker Carlson completely
shredded that narrative. He also brought
in Megan Kelly and other people and he
spoke about what Charlie was going
through because he saw him uh very
shortly before his assassination and he
intimates to everybody what it was
exactly that was on Charlie Kirk's mind
and what he was living through in that
moment. Take a listen.
>> So time after time Charlie would call me
or come to see me and let me know, wow,
or show me text messages. These people
are really mad that you're speaking. And
I would always have the same thought
like I feel pretty moderate actually.
I'm look they felt really mad that he
was speaking. I wonder who got happy
afterward when he died. If if I'm really
mad with somebody and I hear that they
are dead. I think I'll be happy.
Wouldn't I? Guys, don't you think I'll
be happy about it? Think about it. Yeah.
So, who benefited from his killing? I
wonder who. Satan. Never been an Israel
hater. Obviously, I'm not an
anti-semite. I just don't want more wars
and I don't want a foreign country
humiliating my country and telling us
what our laws have to be. I mean, this
seems like pretty basic America first
stuff. And he would say, I totally agree
with you, but they want you off the
stage. And I would always say, no
problem. And he would say, no, it's
important.
It's a matter of principle. I want you
to be there. Great. But I think it's
important to say that out loud because
it's a fact. And there are many liars
out there trying BB Netanyahu number one
among them shamefully
who are trying to distort the truth.
Thank you. Thank you. Alhamdulillah. The
whole world is waking up to these scum
bastards. That's what they are. They've
been persecuting the Palestinians for
decades and finally Allah subhana wa
ta'ala says they plan and Allah plans
and Allah is the best of planners.
Everything backfired on. I even believe
they allowed what happened on October
7th to happen so they can massacre these
people thinking the whole world's going
to be behind them. It didn't work
because evil do his plan and Allah plans
and his best of plans. Even Charlie
Charlie Kirk said there was a standown
order. There was a standown and he got
humiliated.
>> A truth that I know and can prove.
>> Charlie is not the only one who's been
threatened or was threatened to cut ties
with you or not platform you. I too have
gotten that, especially since you've
been more outspoken on Israel. There is
a layer here of nefarious pressure to
have certain narratives go only one way.
>> Yes.
>> That must be called out and must be
fought.
>> It takes
>> Wow. There you go. Even Megan. Even
Megan. Megan saying she's a liar. These
are people close to her. Candace knows
you say now he's a liar. Carl Tox is
saying you're a liar. Joining you're a
liar. Even Joe Rogan knows you're a
liar. The whole world knows you're a
liar. You're a Satan. You're a liar. But
let's just see what Candace Owen has to
say. Follow this lady. And I believe
they're going to try to kill this woman.
And we ask Allahh to guide her to Islam,
the true path of Jesus. Uh following the
one true God. And we ask Allahh to
protect this woman to speak the truth
inshallah at all cost. Subhan Allah. And
guide her to Islam.
>> A truly demonic spirit, right? to be a
part of the people that were swarming,
pressuring, threatening, intimidating
Charlie to then flip in one second after
he dies and say, "Pretend it never
happened." Like they were just great
friends. That's weird to me. They did it
at first regarding me last year. They
insisted and I said, "Charlie, I I
couldn't even come up for air. I didn't
even I said, Charlie, don't even think
about I don't even care. Don't even
fight your donors. Just let them think
they won because I got to rebuild my
entire life. I was just publicly fired.
You know what I mean? Like this is not
you're good. Like you are so good. I
couldn't even care about this less. Like
you're a brother to me. Do what you have
to do to survive. Okay. And then he just
saw them moving into it. Wasn't just
Candace. They wanted Tucker. You're not
allowed to talk to Tucker. Tucker
shouldn't be here. And then Charlie
realized which way the wind was blowing
because it's never enough. It's never
enough with them. Okay. They want to be
the authority on speech. And it is
reality that those very same people who
were pressuring him and threatening him
and intimidating him and calling him an
anti-semite and calling you telling he
was hosting anti-mitism then became the
fastest people to try to eulogize him
and to say look no further. He
effectively died for BB Netany and
Yahoo. It's wrong and we have to stand
up to that narrative.
>> Thank you very much. And we are as
Muslims we are behind because we are
told in Yes. Allah says,
"Come together for truth." Yes. Okay.
Stand together. Meaning come together
whoever it is with. Subhan Allah. Okay.
As for righteousness. So you can see
that inshallah.
>> And you have concerns about Apac.
>> Yes, I do.
>> I'm told that by some people
>> that if I criticize Apac, I'm
anti-Semitic.
>> I think it's ridiculous. Yeah. I I feel
like it's great to have a concern for
your country. Do you think that the that
Apac represents
a kind of cutting in line of
prioritization away from the American
people? Would you guys say that's a fair
summary?
>> Meaning that like, okay, we vote, we're
citizens, but a separate group gets
higher priority because of whatever
reasons. you you you you look like you
want to chime in
>> that the entirety of the idea of a pack
is to represent a group. But the fact
that we're having we're allowing a group
that doesn't even represent American
interests to influence the people who
are supposed to be representing us. I
have a huge problem.
>> So brothers and sisters, as you can see
that subhan Allah, this Satan is
actually actively lying. Why? That's the
reason they they killed him. That's the
reason they killed him. And not only
that, he's coming out and trying to
prove himself, which shows further that
Israel was behind this. They were either
involved directly or indirectly.
Directly meaning they took take they
carried this out somehow with this guy
uh this uh apparently shooter. Number
two, it they knew that that was going to
happen and they have the powers to stop
it. They let it happen. Brothers and
sisters, do not be fooled. Follow
Candace Owens in for more inst. And we
ask Allahh u to deal with these
oppressors who've been doing this for
centuries. And like Candace Owen said
before, if today they are killing the
guards and children and women and
innocent people, tomorrow they're coming
for your Americans. They are coming for
your children next. She said it. Candace
Owens said it and it is the truth. Now
they are coming for your children.
Charlie Kirk and the rest, they are
coming for your children. Your kids are
fighting their battles on those grounds
for their greater Israel project. Wake
up, oh United States of Israel. Wake up.
Till next time.
better.